- [Gary] I think you
used your hand too much,
by the way.
You put your hand
like four times an episode.
(DRock laughs)
I'm right, right?
Yeah, thanks Ty.
(indistinct chatter)
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
Yo, so, this is the
collapse from the high, right?
Great weekend with the guys.
I hate that it's over.
Now, I'm super sad.
You know,
you build up, literally,
months for this moment.
All the prepping,
all the excitement,
all the hype and then boom.
It's over.
Show, that's a good shot.
This is why I know I'm
going to win the league.
Because 90% of
people's sneakers are dorky.
Bunch of fucking dorks.
- [DRock] What's going on here?
- Just getting my sheets ready.
This is Nate.
I love him.
Great, Office of the CEO.
Terrible at
fantasy baseball player.
- Terrible.
- He's actually, he's leaving.
- I'm leaving the league
because I'm so terrible at it.
I mean, are you ready for this?
I just want to
be right, you know?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- And something that I also know
is right is leaving this league.
- [DRock] Why?
- I just think that they can get
a lot more serious player that
will benefit them
for the long term.
- [DRock] And that
makes sense, right?
- I mean, you've
listened to the interviews.
This is a pretty serious league.
- Basically, you're a GM of a
baseball team and you try to
compile a team that will do
the best basically across the
10 different categories
that are picked out.
- Batting average,
home runs, runs,
RBIs, stolen bases,
wins, strikeouts,
WHIP, ERA and saves.
- The compilation of all the
stats throughout the year are
tracked on a website and between
trades and deals you make your
team better either
this year or for the future.
And yeah, eventually,
there's a winner on top
with the best stats.
- Tyler!
- [Tyler] What're you doing?
What're you doing?
- [Gary] The fuck's
going on here?
- [Tyler] Don't be
fucking my shit up.
- [Gary] Ty, this
is taking too long.
Honestly, on a serious note.
There's like all 800 sheets,
where're the pitchers?
- These are pitchers.
- [Gary] Gary Vaynerchuk,
I've been in the league forever.
From the beginning,
from all the beginnings.
I am the
patriarch of everything.
(DRock laughs)
I am, guys.
Fantasy draft is one of my
favorite weekends
of the year, right?
Along with the first
weekend of football
and (laughs) that.
You know, for me outside of the
family time I have at the end of
the year and in late August this
is the time of year I most look
forward to with March Madness,
the NFL draft
and fantasy baseball.
- [AJ] Chop, chop.
- [Gary] Why don't we do
some sort of new category,
like on base percentage?
(crosstalk)
What's the thing you
wanted wins replaced by?
I think we can convince--
- No, you can't.
- Little Lou to go to 500
and then if you go
to 500 it's 10,000.
It sounds good.
(group laughter)
It's also $7,000 to the winner.
Juices are getting going now.
Yep.
(group yelling)
- [Tyler] This is different type
of scenario actually 'cause the
rules are not the
same day as the draft.
Rules are typically a
pretty big conversation.
Two hours and they're typically
at the start of draft and you
come all high energy.
AJ's all jazzed up.
Drew's just kind of in
the corner hanging out.
Grant, he's always on it.
Rules, he's a big
rules discussion guy.
(group laughter)
That saps like
the first two hours.
All of a sudden it's
11:30 and nothings...
(laughs)
- What was the question?
(group laughter)
- [Gary] Let's just do it.
Now, what that means is a guy
like Tapia who I have in my farm
right now, who stays in
my farm, next year--
- [Man] Yes!
- If gets 99at-bats
this year, right.
- [AJ] Basically, Eric Judge
and Jose Veras are lost causes.
- Right, but everybody else.
- [Christopher] Because the past
couple years has seen a huge
escalation in
salary prices for players,
I drafted Clayton Kershaw
last year for $64,
AJ kept him at $64.
You know we have
Mike Trout in the pool.
Golster's back in the pool.
Toovie's back in the pool.
These guys are gonna go for $50+
which if you play in a fantasy
baseball league you're
like that's fucking crazy
but that's like the norm.
That's the floor, so we're gonna
have these guys
going for $50, $60.
- Who do I think it's
gonna win the league this year?
That's a good question.
I think it's gonna be really
tight between Gary and Staats.
- I think I'm going to win it.
- I'm gonna win this league.
- [DRock] Parting words
for Nate and Tyler?
- Look, Nate and
Tyler are, you know,
two nice young men who
over-deliver on many parts of
their lives and under-deliver
in fantasy baseball.
(group laughter)
- [DRock] Who's the one
player you want to get the most?
- The one player I want to get
the most is Paul Goldschmidt,
first baseman.
Has anybody else said that?
- [DRock] No.
I don't think I've heard--
- You're not supposed
to tell me, DRock.
Jesus.
So easy. Keep going.
(group laughter)
Best part, by the way,
best part of the whole film.
- [DRock] You have
anything for DailyVee?
- Yeah, DailyVee so
we did this a year ago.
DRock had no fucking clue
what was going on with fantasy
baseball and we
put up episode 30,
we created no context.
All of you were
like, "What the fuck?"
- [David] Sold. $18.
- That's the man I wanted.
Bang!
Seriously, I wanted him bad.
That's it.
I'm pumped.
Let's go.
Hopefully, this will be a better
episode and I can't wait for the
one hour version of the film to
come out later this month or,
yeah, later this month.
April, good.
Later this month.
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk and this is
the 2017 fantasy baseball draft.
("4AM" by Justin Stone)
(indistinct chatter)
Understood.
But by Tuesday
I'll be normal?
One minute away.
Yeah, understood.
Alright, here we go.
(group laughter)
- So I'm only gonna throw out
championship players to help
everyone so you know
when I throw it out,
this is a guy who has rings.
So first, John Lester.
(light applause)
- [Man 2] 36.
- [David] 36, going once.
Going twice--
- [Man 3] 37.
- [David] Wait, I don't
know who won that one.
- 39.
(several groans)
- [David] 39
going once, going twice.
- [Marcus] 40.
- 40? I think it was Marcus.
Marcus, 40, going once.
- [Man 4] One more.
41 for Brandon.
- [Gary] Always.
- 41 for Brandon, going once.
Going twice, sold (bangs table).
First player sold.
- [Gary] Who is it?
- John Lester.
- [Man 5] For?
- [David] For 41.
- [Gary] Alright,
Brandon you have to go
in the interview room.
It's gonna be a little
longer this year, guys.
Three years ago.
- [David] Going once!
Going twice, 23.
23, going once. 23,
Justin going twice, sold.
- [Gary] Wow, that is
way cheap. Good job, Just.
("4AM" by Justin Stone)
- [David] Some folks
are fading a little bit.
The pressure's
getting to some folks.
I don't know if you
guys have noticed yet.
- [Gary] Why is everybody
moving so much?
(crosstalk)
Come on! Fuck!
I'm literally drinking
rosé out of a milk cup because
I'm doing such a bad job.
I literally want
to drown my sorrows.
I'm doing a terrible job.
I fucked up.
I didn't draft anybody I wanted.
It's a mess.
Besides Chapman I didn't get
a single guy I even wanted.
I'm stunned about
what's going on out there.
- [David] But we're
only halfway through.
I think the folks that are able
to press through these next 45
to an hour is going to
make or break a lot of folks.
Even if you have
a terrible draft,
up until now, think you can
salvage a lot of your season by
finding some gems.
Doing your homework, trying to
get a little lucky, to be honest.
And then making sure you're
playing kind of like what the
market environment
is for the price.
So if folks get gun shy or
they get a little
desperate for a position.
You know there's a lack of
quality third baseman left,
people can start
getting desperate and overpay.
You have to be disciplined.
("Good Yute" by Beno Maslow)
- Over all, doing okay.
Not my greatest draft
ever but not my worst
which is always a good thing.
Didn't like getting Schwarbert
at 30 but I thought I put
together a few other
solid pieces in my outfield and
I think I have some good pieces
so I can get ready to dump
everything come
five hours from now.
- I've been actually
pretty focused for the
first few hours of the draft.
Alan's really
been taking charge,
taking the lead which
is what I wanted him to.
He's found the
league very interesting.
There's some interesting
dynamics that he's not very
accustomed to in his other
leagues but I like the squad.
I think that the
future of
Good Guys, Bad Dudes,
former team name of our,
me and Tyler's legacy,
will be carried on very well.
- Man, this is
such a wild draft.
People are loaded with guys.
- [David] Chris Tillman.
- I got competitive.
Here we go, let's do it.
(group laughter)
- [David] Going once,
to Gary, going twice, sold.
$1.
- Let's go.
(group applause)
Early favorites
are Bobby and Drew.
- The second half,
wasn't as fun as the first one.
Losing Alex Reyes hurt quite a
bit but I'm feeling very good
about my team.
It was very interesting auction.
Can't explain it.
It's hard to say how
it's different from last ones.
Just different, weird pricing.
Weird last hour bids.
AJ did a crazy strategy and
it'll be interesting to see how
that works out.
But still, best day of the year.
Great draft.
- Draft finished really strong.
Got the minor leaguer guys
that I wanted and got all of the
players that I wanted late.
Had to overpay a bit,
but I think it'll work
out in the long term.
I'm much better than
everyone else thinks.
I'm gonna win.
- The surprise row to
wire pick is AJ over Tom.
- [Gary] We did great.
I think I have a
real shot of winning.
Me and AJ just
made another big trade.
I got Carlos Beltran.
We love that.
I think I'm in the mix.
I rallied a little bit.
I feel decent.
I think I have a shot.
Best time, best guys.
All that stuff.
Great weekend.
We'll see what happens but
I think if I had
to pick, it's me.
It's me.
We'll see what happens.
- [DRock] Do you really love it?
- I really love it.
- [DRock] Why?
- It's a great tradition.
It's escapism.
It's something I really care
about that doesn't matter.
Kinda like the Jets, you know?
So I love that.
And I love getting,
you know, Matt Sitomer,
Brant Creyack, even Matt who
works at Vayner is in L.A.
Brant who worked at
Wine Library 15 years.
Even Brandon, my best friend.
Justin Novello, my
brother-in-law but I don't even
see him in the
office that often.
Krup and then
all of AJ's friends.
Marinek and Tom and DeRosa,
I just don't get
to hang out with them.
You know?
I don't get to
hang out with them so...
- [DRock] And you
love the sport of it or
do you like being around them?
- Well, I love being around
them but I love the competition.
I want to win.
I love fantasy baseball, I've
been playing it for 25 years.
- [DRock] Have you won?
- Yeah, I've won a ton.
Remember all those
trophies in my office?
I've won like seven times in
old leagues but this is now the
super league, where we combined
two leagues and I haven't won in
the first four
years which is shocking.
I'm baffled.
So, I have to win this year.
Hey guys, so that is the episode
of DailyVee of our fantasy
baseball draft but
shhh, don't tell anybody,
full film version
coming in a couple of months.
And guess who's gonna be leading
by the time it comes out?
(clicks tongue)
This guy.
("4AM" by Justin Stone)